in um february we began to
um get the impacts of uh kovit
our first school was closed in daegu
korea in the end of february
and within 72 hours we've transitioned
from brick and mortar
in-person school to remote schooling for
our children and we've
learned from that lesson because the
covid went from
korea and then it hit vince vicenza
italy
as a epicenter then spread throughout
europe
and in each case the schools
transitioned to remote learning
and then to the united states so by the
end of march we were
prepared to do the the remote learning
uh so we're predicated on all of this uh
planning and reaction and opening
preparations uh
based on the security of secretary of
defense priorities
which is safety of servicemen uh service
members
uh dod civilians and family members uh
and also tickets to sustain combat uh
combat capabilities our priorities as
the director
are my priorities since the director
eric dodea
is to open schools in a safe environment
for our children and our staff and our
teachers our wonderful teachers
to be the continuity of education and
is israel is important the best
education
is face to face in a classroom and so
our priority is to open every classroom
that we can
safely and flexibility because there's a
remarkable
myriad of situations that we're facing
around the world and unless we
are flexible in our approach we won't be
successful
and to date i think that we've been
remarkably flexible and
cooperative and we coordinating at every
step of the way
next slide please
that's the um
there's there's i i need to to take a
moment
and explain some of the modes of
instruction that we're talking about
uh because it's easily confused between
virtual and remote and they're both
using computers what does it mean
so in circumstances as i said before
teaching children is the best way is
in a classroom with with uh with some of
our great teachers
so that's the number one priority if
it's safe we do that
number two is that that there are
circumstances because of the nature of
the
the covid and and the impact on the
communities
that we can't and so the the
installation would be at a certain
hepcon level in this case would be
charlie
or delta but charlie and we can't open
and so then
we have to continue that education
process through what we call remote
remote schooling is where we have the t
it's geared for
classes and a teacher and think of it as
the teacher is taking their class on the
computer
to their and the children are home and
and and their home
and and they modify the instruction
based on what would have
happened in the classroom uh and it's
with your classmates so it's your class
as you're seeing on the zoom classroom
in the google classroom
you're doing assignments and it's uh in
that sense
it's it's remote but it's classroom
oriented for those specific children
knowing that they will return to brick
and mortar and they will be together
again so that's what we call remote
learning
where teachers go and take their
classrooms home
virtual learning is different we've had
a virtual school for 10 years
it was aimed primarily for high school
students who are in remote locations who
can't take particular courses for
example
ap chemistry would be difficult to do
if we don't have the staff and the
equipment at a remote high school
so they're allowed to do it through
virtual schools where the curriculum is
designed for computers
we have instructors teachers who who
lead the process
basically student driven a student sets
their own schedule
and completes the course too standard um
in a virtual setting so it's designed
from start to finish as a virtual
whereas remote uh it it's
a the curriculum is modified but it's a
uh
the it's uh bringing the the brick and
mortar classroom to the computer
as opposed to virtual which is designed
from start to finish student driven
um for for that type of instruction
so knowing that within our seventy
thousand students and and our parents
that we support
uh there would be some hesitation on
returning their children to
uh to what we consider very safe
classrooms in in a
hepcon bravo and so what we did was
about three weeks ago we offered the
opportunity
for parents who are unsure or not
comfortable with sending their children
to a brick and mortar school
to be to participate in the virtual
school
and the commitment for the virtual
school is one semester
as opposed to a whole year but one
semester
and and we had about 1200 students
in the high school portion we've
expanded
the virtual school from kindergarten
through high school
and now we have 10 000 students enrolled
we've offered our teachers an
opportunity to teach in the virtual
school
about 10 percent indicated that they
would like to do that so we're
professionally developing them and
providing them the uh
the the background and expertise to be
uh virtual instructors so those are the
modes of instruction so we will be
open in some cases open where children
are in classrooms with teachers in a
safe environment according to cdc
standards
we will have remote where teachers will
be with their class in classes with
their
with their classmates and virtual which
is designed for
student-led instructor-driven
classes so those are the three different
modes of instruction that we intend to
execute this opening year so
next slide please
as i said the planning process has been
began six months ago uh the good news is
we're learning lessons from what we went
through with the remote learning
in march through the end of the year
and we've incorporated all of the cdc
guidance
and the department of defense guidance
into our opening of school
execution at the the school level so our
administrators and our teachers are
aware of the safety measures that have
been put in place
and as you can see there we in the
second box
those are all the covid 19 requirements
that we had to
make to insert in our planning process
to procure the necessary face masks the
necessary antiseptic the
face washing in selected
places to put barriers that we will
clean we had to extend custodial
contracts to make sure that
that it's clean to cdc standards
work with commanders and that's really
the key to the department of defense
schools
is that we are hand in hand with each
one of the local commanders
and all the facilities and all the
expertise that they have to include
their medical staff
we designed a very in-depth uh
guide on how to open school safely their
staff and the commanders personally
reviewed it
gave us input we had changed it
accordingly
and and now we're in version two soon to
be version three as we
update from the cdc and their latest
guidance
uh and and input from the field so
there's two elements where the local
commanders
and their community can input and i'll
give an
anecdotal example in europe a very
senior commander
reviewed the plan very comfortable with
it is going to execute it
and told his community this isn't a
dodea opening of school plan
this is our opening of school plan and
it's the community's opening of school
plan
and i'm very comfortable in how we're
executing and i think that that kind
of closeness or coordination is very
very critical as we go forward
um and and now we're in the the supplies
are
are out in the field they're in the
school the administrators the principals
and staff have done a wonderful job
in addressing the social distancing and
the
the lunch programs and how the children
will get them and grab and go
and where they will be what spaces will
be available to ensure that it's being
taken care of
uh that's in our brick and mortar
openings uh
and and now we'll continue to our
opening begins next week and some quite
cases in the
the united states and and that's where
we'll go next slide please
this gives you an overview of what we're
doing in the around the world the green
indicates
the schools that will be open in brick
and mortar in person
where staff will welcome the teachers
we'll be there
students will be there the yellow
indicates those that installations and
schools that will be open remotely
and again this is where the child will
be with their classroom on a computer
and then the virtual school which isn't
certain with ten thousand students will
be operating from three different hubs
around the world
uh and and we look forward to uh
excellent opening in school i would tell
you that that will be successful because
we have a remarkably dedicated staff of
teachers
who are all teachers are great but ours
are very special because they have that
additional mission
of taking care of them the children of
the men and women who
we put in harm's way for defense of the
united states and that's an additional
mission because we have an impact on
readiness and we have an impact on
on retention and so i think that's my
overview i think that concludes the
slides and i'm
open to any questions that you may have
okay we'll uh we'll go uh
first to the phones and go through
questions obviously i'm happy to take
questions uh mr brady's giving this time
up today so uh to offer up so if you
have questions for him we want to make
sure to
make taking use of his time right now so
we'll go uh
bob burns ap uh
yeah thank you jonathan um i have a
question for each of you if i mr brady
um for those of us who are on the phone
and can't see the slides you refer to
um it may be just me but i don't
understand the um
the breakdown of numbers you've got the
you mentioned 10
000 are enrolled for the virtual schools
but does that mean everybody else is
going to be
returning to the how many return to
actual school
in person they
will all be returning to school but as i
said before the nuance between remote
and actual brick and mortar so the slide
that you didn't see and i'm sure we
could provide it to you
is the numbers of schools that will be
open face-to-face with teachers
and the others that will be uh virtual
so i think bob and if you'd like the
numbers i'd be glad to give it to you in
the pacific region we'll have 13
19 of 45 schools operating remotely
and that'd be okinawan two locations in
japan
in europe only two of the 64 schools
will be opening remotely in there in
bahrain
and in the united states 25 of 50
schools will be opening remotely
to include fort benning and fort bragg
among others
and so that's the breakdown and did i
answer your question sir
um well i was wondering the the numbers
of students
uh you mentioned the number of schools
but does that is that can you also give
the breakdown a number of students
for each those three i'd be glad to
provide it to you i don't have it in
front of me
um but it's seven to seventy thousand
okay bob we'll get back to you on that
so it's it's a number will be
uh in person 10 000 will be on the
virtual
some will be remote uh but we can get
that uh more accurate breakdown to you
all right uh ask you something on a
barbara
topic quickly if i might um can you tell
us
if the military the defense department
is now
both prepared and willing to step in
and provide support to civil authorities
if asked for any post-election
unrest or any support for the election
so with respect to the election itself
obviously we have a role that we play
supporting
hhs and sorry dhs and fbi in regard to
election security so
i'll i'll defer you with uh to the
national counterintelligence security
center director's comments on
efforts by actors malign actors
to affect our elections and our efforts
on election security
but dhs and fbi are the federal
government leads to deal with
interference in our election
we will not tolerate interference from
foreign officials
in our election process and against our
democratic institutions so
we're in a support role obviously
cybercom and others have some role i'm
not going to speak to that but i'd refer
you to fbi and dhs
with regard to that for the other part
of your question
i would just say we have a constitution
and our constitution which all members
of the military have sworn an oath to
provides no role for the u.s military's
arbiter of political or election
disputes
this issue appears to be born of
unserious thought reflecting
a fundamental lack of appreciation for
the history of our democracy
and the civilian military relationship
established under our constitution
right let me just uh the the point i was
trying to ask is in the military u.s
military
does have a role when asked for
supporting
civil authorities when requested on any
number of
issues so our support to civil
authorities so
are you as you have in recent civil
unrest
uh is the u.s military prepared and
willing
to take on that task or do you
cross it off the list of things you will
not do would you be
prepared if asked to support
civil authorities if there was election
post-election
unrest i think i'm going to let my my
statement stand i'd say that that's a
hypothetical
so i don't really have a i have a
comment for you on the hypothetical
you've laid out there other than the
statement i've already given
thank you lucas jonathan any update on
the air force helicopter that was shot
at earlier this week over northern
virginia
we're working with the fbi to track down
some information uh and they're doing
leading the investigation into
what took place obviously uh greatly
concerned with uh
individuals that would take
a direct fire one of our aircraft
performing a flight
in the u.s fortunately there were no
serious injuries and
it could have been a very tragic
situation so we're going to work with
the fbi
and try to get to the bottom as quickly
as we can and for mr brady
yes why is it important that children go
to school in person
i think uh if you ask any educator in
the united states they say that
the adult the talented teacher interface
with the children the social interaction
between the pupils in the classroom
the the ability to uh to to oversee
tasks as they occur
make corrections make sure they're
meeting standards
it's just absolutely a better situation
for student achievement
the best the next best given the
circumstances
is remote train teachers who know how to
do
google classroom children who can zoom
and we've had practice at it and we've
gotten better the statistics indicated
that it was a remarkable
shaky start because who knew
but by the end of the period that we had
going last year
we were up to 98 percent of students
within 9-12 or
daily on their computer turning in
assignments
attendance etc so it was a learning
curve but it's
it's not ideal but but it's the best
next best
and should students be playing sports
this fall including football
that's it literally
athletics at these schools
all our decisions are not necessarily
the school decisions
i mean it's not dodea's decision it's
based on department of defense guidance
and and what the
uh the health condition is within that
area
and so for hepcon charlie installations
in hepcon charlie
there's absolutely no sports um
whatsoever
we follow the the the american high
school
and athletic association guidance on
this
and and there will be uh and b there's
some
sports so track and field for example
golf some swimming but non-contact and
and limited number of adults and they do
it safely but that's the extent that we
go
the key is that we're going to follow
the guidelines and to make sure that
the experience for our students are as
safe as possible
and as we've seen you know the
difference between the department of
defense and other organizations is that
uh
as as mr brady mentioned we have an
obligation to the family members who are
serving
uh to take care of their kids and take
care of their their families uh so that
that so that they are prepared and it's
a readiness issue so we're going to
continue to do that
um i'm going to go to the phones real
quick do a couple questions uh sylvie
hello thank you um i have two questions
actually
um for you jonathan i would like to know
if you have any details on the um
incident
in the omanci today or yesterday um
with the um with iran
and explain us why the coalition didn't
intervene and also general mckenzie
yesterday
seemed to confirm that u.s is helping
the sdf to exploit
the oil fields in the north east of
syria
so i wanted to know how it works if
there is an american oil company
involved
and what the legal basis
for this is okay so i'll take the first
question
uh briefly i don't have a much of an
update for you
on the information that was provided by
centcom yesterday
obviously it is no secret that iran has
been a destabilizing force in the region
whether it's attacking targets in saudi
arabia and structured targets in saudi
arabia
disrupting commercial shipping through
the use of mines
or disruptive behavior
the the use of cyber attacks funding
terrorist organizations
through throughout the region ballistic
missile attacks
on iraq so it's it's it's not a surprise
to anyone that
iran has continued with this behavior i
understand that later today the imsc
will have a briefing where they'll
provide an additional update
for the events that took place yesterday
and so i would ask you to tune in for
that
i believe your second question was
regarding syrian oil fields is that
correct silly
yes it is thank you so i i'd refer you
back to
general mckenzie's comments but
generally as we've seen
in in syria with regard to the oil
fields
the goal is to prevent the terrorist
organizations
uh from having access to the oil to fund
their operations
uh we've seen tens of millions of
dollars in the past per year go to
uh their their funding of weapons
systems their exporting of terrorism
and so by preventing them from obtaining
those oil fields it prevents them from
having that source of revenue
it additionally allows the our partners
in the region
who can actually control those oil
fields to use the funds from that
to maintain defensive operations to
help them defeat terrorist efforts in
the area and also to fund
efforts to rebuild their communities all
right
so we'll go next to adress
thanks um i had a quick question uh
about the schools um and specifically
about the
teachers um if in the schools the
teachers
um any number of teachers refuse to
teach because they don't feel safe
coming in
or with the precautions taken um are
there any penalties
um and same with students what if a
student
refuses to come into school because he
or she doesn't feel safe with the
precautions taken
what avenues do they have or are they
just going to be left
no known child will be left so
as i understood your question we have
the procedures and protocols established
for staff members who exhibit symptoms
or or cannot come to to work
and we'll take appropriate measures to
provide
qualified substitutes or whatever and
make sure that the
the instructor takes the the right
procedures with the local
medical officials etc and gets tested
for students it's a similar procedure
where parents will check the child
before they
go to school in terms of temperature and
any symptoms
and then they will work with the
their local medical facility on testing
and further
quarantine that's necessary until
recovery to come back
if a child's out for more than four days
our student support team
will make sure that they will check on
their status and then provide
packets of instruction to make sure that
they keep their continuity of education
so there's multiple ways that we will
take care and plan for
the inevitable positive results but
we are comfortable in that no child
it sounds like a cliche no child will be
left behind but obviously we take very
very serious
charge of our students and we will sure
that they will take care of
be taken care of instructionally okay
stay on the phones
uh and we'll go to uh courtney
what happens if a child opts out of
school
or a parent who's fearful of the
securities
well that's why we set up the uh the
virtual school option
so that they can be part of that virtual
school
and all students all teachers can opt
out without all teachers
students on a case-by-case basis the
parents can contact the principal
and the local superintendent and see
what availability and taking care of the
the
child so there is an opportunity for
those to go to a virtual school
about a teacher though who doesn't feel
well the teacher's already well
it is again a case-by-case basis it
depends on them we have what's called a
reasonable accommodation procedure
within the
opm and many of our about 500 of our
teachers have put in for reasonable
accommodation based on that of
self-evaluation
with a proper medical documentation we
will make sure that they are reasonably
accommodated to include perhaps
instruction in the
virtual school all right so go to the
phone we'll go to tony capaccio
hi john for mr brady can you i had a
question for mr brady and for you
of the 10 000 students can you break
down how many are in the united states
versus overseas bases
and for john the secretary went down to
visit the b-21 bomber
yesterday development we don't hear a
lot about that program
what were his impressions of the program
what was he briefed on and does he have
any concerns about its cost or
development at this point
i'll just quickly take that one um he
did he did not
go down to the b-21 yesterday uh he
traveled previously
uh the the b-21 program is an important
aspect of our nuclear triad and our
future bomber forces
uh and uh we're committed to seeing its
development
and and and eventual testing and launch
i can't really talk about any specifics
on the program right now
but that's our commitment is to see that
program through
and as a breakdown of students yes uh in
in the united states there's 4
330 students who are enrolled in the
virtual school
in europe it's 3184
and in the pacific it's 2158.
which is which is 1028 but i rounded it
to 10
000. okay are there any more are there
any difficulty uh
specific challenges in virtual learning
for for kids in the pacific theater
versus those in the us
in terms of the technology the links the
the the command to control pipes so to
speak
uh no actually the the uh
a problem it's uh the connectivity is
is been done we've addressed it well
we have hot spots that that are given to
students who who need them
wi-fi hotspots we've distributed over 7
000
chromebooks which are the connectivity
to the virtual school
we have not had connectivity issues and
of course our hub is in the pacific with
the instructors so
it's a good time zone and they are
talking to one another so
no we haven't run into that and when we
did we addressed it with the
virtual hot spots all right we'll go to
a matt saylor from abc
hi thank you both uh mr brady i just
want to make sure i understand the
difference between virtual and remote
schooling
remote schooling would be done in
locations
for which brick and mortar is not an
option because of the local conditions
and virtual
is offered in places where brick and
mortar is offered but people aren't
comfortable is that correct
it's um yeah i i think you have it if i
could go just a little bit further the
brick and mortar the
the remote is in a short term
answer to keeping students and teachers
together
while they're pending return to the
brick and mortar a virtual
is a separate curriculum designed to be
a school that's a semester long
with uh electives etc etc so yeah i
think
i i think you got it okay um we'll come
back here
to the room jeff thank you mr brady you
had said the
cause the chances of a positive test are
inevitable
has dodea looked at the risk
that students may die by returning to
school if so are
students at increased risk of dying
um look jeff i think that everyone
acknowledges
that the covit is uh as a
terrible and difficult disease that
we're dealing with we're putting in the
best measures we possibly can to
mitigate any risk
that includes face masks that include
social distancing hand washing all the
things that mr brady went through
we at the department of defense we've
continued to
operate all of our efforts around the
world
the schools is one thing where we're
going to continue to operate we
acknowledge that there's risk
we're giving parents and teachers the
option if they
believe that that risk is uh is more
than they're willing to
to take on to seek out addition
alternatives
to being in class as mr brady talked
about we have
the virtual learning environment that's
available to them as well
and so that this is going to be
something where we're working with
communities we're working with parents
we're working with teachers
to reach the solution that's best for
them and to limit the risk as much as
possible thank you i would like to hear
mr brady's answer that's right welcome
to laura
um thank you for doing this so two
questions one for mr brady um
are there any plans to test children
preventatively
to try to make it so they're not going
to get covered
and safeguarding against bringing the
disease back to their older relatives
and then jonathan for you just on the
syria oil field
what responsibility does the u.s
military have in the region to protect
the work on the oil fields given what
you said
about keeping the resources out of the
hands of isis
i'm i'm sorry i'm old and i might have
missed the first part of your question
are we
any tests are there any plans to test
children preventatively
uh no not at this time is that something
that you've considered doing or do you
just not have that uh yeah well
again it's it's uh we work with the
local commanders and the local medical
experts and that is not um
an option that that appeared viable or
or
necessary according to the cdc okay
uh on the oil fields question um i i'd
refer you over to centcom
on what the the actual role is going to
be in the area
um i would just say that we've been
working with our partners in the area to
protect
uh our partners protect americans in the
area protect our forces
we continue to have the right of
self-defense but other than that i don't
have anything
any specifics for you all right okay
caitlyn penny from stars and stripes my
question is on
whether does dodea provide any food
assistance programs such as reduced
lunches
and if so are you making sure that
children who are
maybe remote or virtual can take
advantage of that in any way
um thank you yes we do we have we
provided
over one million grab-and-go lunches
in the spring when our children were
remote
at no cost to parents so they would
drive up to the school get the lunch and
drive on so we're
keenly aware of the impact of nutrition
on learning
and we did have that grab and goes
established
and we will continue to provide proper
meals to
within the fda guidelines and so we're
pursuing
uh that continuation of that program
thank you okay so i have two questions
actually
first do you have anything on friends
plan to send
jets and ships to the eastern
mediterranean
because of the tension of course between
turkey and
greece and second do you have any update
any new information
about the cause behind that explosion in
beirut
so first on on beirut we're going to
once again
terrible tragedy that has taken place in
beirut
we the u.s has been continuing to assist
the lebanese people and the lebanese
government the department of defense is
supporting usaid the
the lead agency from the u.s government
i know the acting administrator john
barza
is either he's in lebanon now or is soon
to visit
to help coordinate relief efforts so the
usncom has been sending aircraft with
relief supplies
including food water medical supplies
and
we'll continue to do that whether it's
it's through centcom
european command has uh six usaid
purchased interagency emergency
health kits from the netherlands that
flew through ramstein and have been
delivered
uh that have the ability to help local
hospitals support up to 60 000 people
for three months so
we've been providing a lot of resources
in terms of the investigation itself
we're continuing to refer to
the lebanese government as they they
work through the investigation
we will as i mentioned last week if
asked we'll
be able to provide assistance to them
but we're not going to get ahead of
them reaching the conclusion making a
statement about the the causes of the
explosion
on france and france in turkey
in the eastern red obviously concerned
with
with some of the incidents that have
taken place in the mediterranean
french and nato are both incredibly
important nato allies
and we would like to see the tensions
lowered and so we would like to see them
continue to work together
and find solutions that do not involve
the necessity of having warships or have
aircraft deployed in a
less than cooperative environment all
right we'll go back to the phones real
quick
uh courtney cooby
thanks my question's been answered okay
all right i have a question
uh well let me keep going through here
hold on um uh
karen from military times
hi thanks for taking my question um mr
brady who is responsible for cleaning
the classrooms is are the teachers
going to be responsible for some of that
and
in terms of your 21st century classrooms
that are more open are they going to
require more resource
resources to deal with cova good
question yes they do
and we've already modified our custodial
contracts around the world to uh
account for the additional cleaning to
uh cdc standards
but inside the classroom uh there
there are and teachers will be provided
the the proper cleaning materials but
they're not
um we're designing like the
instructional material to
to have a minimal amount of required
cleaning
and by that i'm talking about the
manipulates the the
the younger children where they're using
the blocks and the legos they will be
individually
bagged for each child so you don't have
that
passing and it doesn't require the
teacher to take valuable time to do that
so we're not expecting our teachers to
be to be custodial workers
uh we're taking the proper planning to
make sure that that that's
not not part of their process
but there are areas that they will and
and they've been instructed
to do that and i know they will gladly
all right we'll go to uh
uh fadi mansour al jazeera
hi jonathan thank you i have i have two
questions uh
we've seen lately a couple of uh news
reports
about the state of uh defense
partnership between the u.s and
qatar specifically claiming that qatar
has been supporting hezbollah which
puts u.s troops in the middle east
in danger do you see any credibility to
these reports and do you have any
does the dod have any plans to change uh
the military posture um
in laodicea air base in qatar and and
second question
the u.n security council is taking up
the issue of renewing
the ban on exporting weapons to iran the
question is
if the the security council failed in in
doing so
what kind of challenges do you see
to the u.s presence in the region if
iran was able to
acquire new weapon systems
so on iran i've mentioned our concerns
with iran's
destabilizing behavior the u.s
government believes that the
the ban on weapons sales is an important
provision in place to help
diminish iranian misadventure and
they're
well known as the leading state sponsor
of
terrorists in the around the globe and
so
we believe that that ban is important
i'll defer you
over to state i refer you over to state
department for
for comments about the actual vote at
the u.n and what may take place
but we believe it is necessary and we
believe it's important that that uh that
prohibition stay in place
um on your your first question with
cutter i don't have any specifics on
that i'll just say
look we we evaluate our partnerships uh
around the world on a frequent basis we
expect
all of our partners to to to be good
partners and to
behave responsibly i don't have any
specific comments with regard to
the allegations and recent reporting
all right we'll keep going a couple more
people i think um
uh patricia from military.com
yes thanks for uh taking my question is
there like a
threshold of um you know how many like a
percentage
of how many kids or teachers might have
positive
before you will go to remote learning
like what is that decision process
going to be uh the decision process is
that the child will be
uh either it occurs but it the parent
will take the child to the medical
facility if it occurs at home obviously
but if it's school
and and the students refer to a nurse
the nurse will take appropriate action
to the mtf and should it be a positive
result
we will close for three two to three
days to ensure that the school
completely sanitized and the child is
taken care of properly if we get past
three days where we have to close then
we will go
to a remote i'm sorry the sixth today
if we get three to two to five we will
sanitize et cetera and return the
children
if it gets to the sixth day then we will
go to a remote setting and so that would
be the trigger
okay we'll keep going uh jennifer from
air force magazine
thank you so much for taking my question
so
i have two questions the first is can
you please speak to mr brady
which air force installation schools
will be opening um in person versus
remotely
and then second dod wide i'm curious as
to what if any resources that doda plans
to make available
to military families to ease the burden
of remote and virtual learning on
service members and their spouses
especially in cases where either both
parents are
serving or a civilian spouse is still
employed i'll i'll jump in on the first
one
we're not we're not going to lead
through read through the list of all the
installations we'll
we'll work on getting a list for each
installation that's out there
but we're not going to read through all
of them right now but we'll the second
one the second one is
the burden of the virtual school
actually we thought of it as a
boon to to give parents a choice
as they make an informed choice the our
impact on readiness and making sure that
the service members are where they
should be is critical and that's why our
emphasis was on
opening in brick and mortar i know that
we
the local commanders are looking at
every possible way
expand cdc's child development center
child care centers etc
and so we we
in from dodea from our perspective we
are
trying to get to as many non-remote
schools to open face-to-face
person-to-person
uh the virtual school is provided as an
option for those parents who make that
conscious decision
uh that that it's best for their family
and their students to
to do that so i i thought that would be
a plus
all right um and then we'll go uh to uh
newsy i think i heard you on the phone
uh there earlier but just calling on you
now
yeah thank you so much for taking my
question um this is from mr brady
what is being done for students that
have learning disabilities as far as
remote or virtual learning are there any
special classes specifically for those
with specific learning disabilities
absolutely and in fact we just put out
uh for our
uh virtual workforce and the remote
teachers a very
uh thorough uh procedure guide for the
types of
how to improve their professional
development providing instruction
or what additional resources will be
provided
so that we meet the requirements of ieps
and at the same time 504 accommodations
and so we have been again from our
practice in the spring
we address the special education needs
of our fragile children
very well and remote as we can
so we've got the right resources the
right professional development
and and we're working with each student
individually
okay okay can you tell us what some of
those resources are
say if you have a student who may be
autistic and can't really
um learn well on using computers like
what
give us some examples of some of those
additional resources
um that you would be applying absolutely
so we were talking about
that we would allow additional time for
uh that that child
for for a given uh lesson
we understand it would be uh a longer
time we'd also talk about
uh we'd also uh refer the the the
parents to
uh very uh in-depth uh websites to provo
what they can do at the home to assist
the child
we also would call in any experts for a
particular
need for a child in an extended
remote learning and perhaps that they
weren't
with a normal class schedule would work
and so we would have
experts work with them afterwards so it
would be based on an individual
and the resources and printed material
we would also send them printed material
and any other educational aides we could
provide the parents to assist us
caitlin last question um on the
shutting down to school to clean it and
then bring it back yes
what is your anticipation if it you have
to keep opening and shutting schools
because of cases like you shut up for
three days you're back for a week
another kid gets sick or a teacher
you have to close it for another two
days and having to go like open and
closing and remote like
what's the criteria i guess to go fully
remote for a semester like are you
anticipating the up and down or what do
you
um we're we're flexibility was part of
the four pillars of designing these and
if it would be case by case and and
in circumstances where it's bravo korea
for example
um we have our installations there there
uh the local commanders have said their
bravo they haven't had a reported case
in a period of time so
that appears to be an excellent example
of where brick and mortar will be and
continuing
the rest is is flexibility in the fact
that we can't anticipate what's going to
happen in a local community
and if it gets to a certain point which
i'm not prepared to say what that point
is yet um will balance between taking
care of
of of kids for uh to to make sure their
education is good and take care of
readiness for their parents to be at
work
and and there will be a balance and we
will reach it and
it's part of our planning but i'm not um
we haven't we're prepared for it but we
haven't we're not going to announce what
that is
at this point jonathan any plans to
reduce the number of u.s troops in iraq
or syria in the coming months
i don't have any announcements for you
right now um so just uh
i want to thank mr brady for coming and
thank you guys for your questions
obviously this is an incredibly
important issue for the department
and maintaining our commitment to our
families and it's very clear that the
defense education activity has a
an incredibly thorough uh plan we'll
share with you guys the
the slides as well as the list of
installations we'll get that guys that
out to you guys quickly and
this will change as some of the
conditions change in certain areas and
the list may be modified and there'll be
differences and uh we'll update that but
thank you guys for this it's important
to get this information out to the
families
and students over the next week or so
before school starts thank you guys
thank you very much
you